は：あーでももう一歩なんですよー
た：ホントに？　　　　は：うん。
は：だいぶ、キレイ。。
うん。。
そうでもねえわ(・。・;
さあ、やってまいりましたよ！
今回もきましたよ！
今回もやってまいりました
人気企画『たくみふくしゃちょーの、肌を治せ』の
コーナーです！！（歓声）
前回、コラーゲンの大量摂取に挑んだんですけれどもww
結果から言うと、まあ失敗...
た：え、でも…
た：失敗...　は：良くはなってますね(；一_一)
彼の肌質を改善しつつ、肌に良い情報を
皆さんに伝えられれば良いなと思っております！
今回用意した企画は、コチラです！！
はいはいはい！　た：(・。・;
は：今回はコチラを使っていきます！
角栓スッキリ毛穴パック！
毛穴パックですね、こういう感じで貼ってめくると
毛穴の角質がとれるというものでございます！
僕中学生の時、多分たくみんの比になんない位
ニキビが酷かったんですよ。　た：絶対嘘だ！！
俺中学校の時水ぼうそうみたいな顔してたからね！
は：wwww
は：結構酷くて、色々ニキビについて
調べたんですけれども、なぜ、ニキビがおきるか
っていうと、毛穴が詰まってしまって
炎症が起きているんですよ。
だからもう、単純な話
毛穴を開いて汚れを取って、スッキリさせれば、
もう確実にニキビが減るんじゃないかという感じで
場所が場所なんで（？）広範囲に及んでいるので
二人：www
鼻だけではなく、なるべく広範囲に及んで
角質をキレイにしていければ良いなと、
思っております！
た：おおーありがたい！　いやー嬉しい！
今日はキレイにしていきましょう！w
た：いやでも前回より期待...
た：いや前回と同じくらい期待できるよ
は：ww
は：今回物理的にホントに
角質が取れていくわけですから
た：そうだもんね
は：えー、毛穴パック500枚準備しましたーー
た：(+_+)
は：もうあなたの穴という穴（意味深）が
キレイになりますからね
あ、こういう感じで入ってるんだ。10枚入ってます。
じゃあ早速貼っていきましょう！
まずは、まんべんなく顔を濡らしていきます。
た：(*_*;　なんかいいニオイするんだけど何これw
た：うおおっ！
は：ああ目閉じて！目閉じて！
は：ホントにね、これで多分濡らさないと
肌が荒れちゃうんで
ここでしっかり濡らしていくことが大事でございます。
た：(；一_一)
は：あ、でも良い感じで濡れてますねー
で、ここからはスピード勝負で
なるべくたくみの毛穴に
パックを貼っていきましょう！
こういう感じか。
あ、良いんじゃない、良いんじゃない？うん
良い感じ、良い感じ。　おおー、おっけおっけ
こういう感じでどんどん貼っていきます。
こめかみとか結構気になると思うんだよね。
＞＞早送り
↑　みんな:ww
はい、という訳で顔はほぼ完成したので、
あとは体ですね。
ニキビというのは体のどこにできるか分かりません。
毛穴がつまったら、
炎症が起きてニキビになってしまいますので、
なるべくある分だけでうめていこうと思います。
二人：wwwww
↑
は：すいません、口周りは避けろって書いてあったので
口周りは避けときます。
貼った後でごめんなさい。
は：はい！という訳で貼り終わりましたー！
素晴らしい！
素晴らしいですねー！
今これで、毛穴パックで毛穴を
開けて、中のそのー角質とか古いアレ（？）を
取り出して、おります！　今の感想は？
は：はい、ありがとうございます。。
という訳で、そうですね、取る前にぐるっと
回ってみてもらいましょうか。
は：はい...　た：( 一一)
は：おおーー＾＾
ホラー映画じゃん、もうw
ちょっとぐるっと回ってみましょうか。
は：おおー上手ですねー
素晴らしい（？）ですねー
はい、という訳でこんな感じにですね、全体的に
貼ってあるんですけれども、これを今から全部取って、
毛穴がキレイになった本人と、
これを貼る前だったbeforeの彼を、
比較してみましょう！
た：（メキメキッ）
は：ああー、おーすごい
た：ウォーーーーーー
た：ウォーーッ　は：ww
た：ウゥッ
は：（苦笑）
は：うわ、めっちゃ落ちるじゃん
大事なのは、顔なんすよね。
た：いきます。　は：いってみましょうか。
た：いててっ！いたいいたい！！
た：いきます。
は：はい！　どれだけ取れているかですね。
た：ウォーー
は：うわ、取れてる、取れてる！すごい！×３
めっちゃ取れてる！
はあ、待って、ホントに肌キレイになってない？
↑
ご視聴ありがとうございます！
初字幕、どうでしたか？